thoughts on Tucker on tuck Tucker's
growth and what he's doing right now and
how he's exploding his shows all over
the place getting the kind of eyeballs
that he's getting what do you think
about what he's doing um no I think he's
going to go the way I ought to say I
think the only good things he ever said
on his show he he stole from me um many
and the crazy stuff about UFOs and we're
all going to die of Co you probably
don't remember that oh yeah he was the
one who drove to Mara Lago to tell the
president you've got to shut down the
country yeah got a lot of good press for
that um and January 6 was all FBI Asians
crazy um so not a fan and I think he's
going the way of of the rest of them I
mean it shows you at least it used to I
think this is changing and thanks to
podcasts like yours podcasts are so much
bigger now people are cutting cable no
one under the age of 60 owns a
television set and that is so good for
the for the conservative movement
because fox has had way too much power
too long and it shows you the power of
that media real estate going back to um
um I forget some of the early ones
paulon Glenn Beck um Megan Kelly uh Bill
O'Reilly
Tucker once they're gone they're kind of
gone you mentioned January 6 how do you
feel meaning meaning they're done done
like no but you have you have just been
given the most wonderful you won a
lottery ticket if you get a show at
least it used to be the case I think
this is changing on Fox news for one
thing I think they're not they're not as
interesting or smart anymore so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here